aujourd'hui c'est une marche des fiertés
radical antiraciste et anticapitaliste
c'est important d'avoir des lieux
deux rencontres entre personnes qui est
partie 2
l'idée
un peu marginalisés dans la société
aujourd'hui et c'est super important
aussi d'avoir une convergence
les luttes et de dire qu on est tous
ensemble en fait dans ce groupe acquis
qui nous concerne tous pensent que la
marche des fiertés c'est d'abord
marche de revendications au droit à
l'existence et ne
une revendication au 6e
pleine citoyenneté en fait parce que
[Musique]
droit et et voilà on est là pour montrer
plus on a le droit d'être là dans
l'espace
et pour n'existe
je
[Musique]
les blancs dernière
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m